hey welcome the monitor Peter Rubin
senior editor at Wired we got some
curveballs for you this week but I want
to start it off with a reality show I
know I know it's been on for a couple of
weeks I know I'm late on it but against
everything I assumed king of the nerds
on TBS is the best reality show I have
seen in a very long time you may have
seen the trailer as you know the deal
its kind of two teams against each other
doing nerd things and you think oh this
is going to be the most kind of
exploitative stereotypical reduction of
what nerds are now the people who made
this are also the people who host it
that's Curtis Armstrong and robert
carradine who you may know as booger and
Lewis from Revenge of the Nerds so their
idea when they took it to TBS was hey
let's kind of do Revenge of the Nerds as
a competition reality show and what
comes through is love for nerdom and
authenticity so you've got the full
range of the usual type you've got the
hacker you've got the scientist the
neuroscientist the larper the fantasy
writer you've got the woman who got our
PhD at some ungodly young age and is now
a planetary physicist at NASA so you
have intellect encapsulated in all its
forms but the challenges that they make
them do range from trivia to playing
chess to whatever it is and it's done
well they cast this really well and they
edited it well it is not it is not a
show of ridicule to show of love and
it's actually remarkably entertaining
and that is on Thursday nights on TBS
week 3 is this week it won't be hard to
figure out what's going on that's the
nice thing about shows like this they
are simple enough to just jump into so I
implore you to check that out even if
you think it's going to be dumb talk
about music okay I I talk so much about
new music that is out this week new
music that is out this week that I
actually want to take some time to talk
about some old music that is out this
week it's new this week but it's only
about 80 years old I'm talking about
Jack White's label third man records is
taking this week to introduce the first
three volumes or the fur
volume of the first three artists in
their kind of complete recorded work
series they're taking early delta blues
artists and they're giving them the
loving vinyl treatment this was these
were kind of produced in conjunction
with document records which is a
uk-based label that has rights to a ton
of early Delta blues musicians Blind
Willie McTell is probably the one that
you've heard of the most but there's
also charlie patton who's widely
acknowledged as the originator of delta
blues and then there are mississippi
sheiks who were a fiddle and guitar
family band for lack of a better term
who have a song sitting on top of the
world that's been covered by basically
every blues musician you can think of
Big Bill Broonzy version is the one that
I always think of but it's nice to have
kind of such a well-curated and well
compiled thing so the Charlie Patton one
it looks like it's going to have four
volumes that are going to be released
serially Blind Willie McTell is also
going to have four volumes Mississippi
chic is going to have five they had a
bit more output than the other two I
mean we're talking about the late 1920s
and the very early 1930s but this is
just you know I'm a big blues fan
especially early stuff and Delta stuff
so it's a great for me as someone who
also loves final to be able to get this
stuff if you are not a vinyl person this
stuff is always available kind of on CD
and digital download and and a lot of
people are taking care to kind of scrub
old 78 and put out good remasters of
recordings but if you are a vinyl person
actually let me do a very very quick
unboxing you can kind of see what the
what the record looks like my one beef
and this is the x DJ and me talking is
that these are just kind of two side LP
so you're looking at eight tracks on the
side seven or eight tracks on a side
which is great to get a bunch of music
on final not the best if you're looking
to play this out it's just a you know
it's a lot of tracks put onto one side
that is
tiny tiny quibble so if you're a DJ I
doubt your lien taking this out and
trying to mix it up anyway so don't even
worry about that so third man records
complete recorded histories of various
great Delta bluesman that starts this
week check those out let's talk about
games okay now I haven't spoken about
video games in a while but there is
something coming to the app store this
week iOS App Store that I am very
excited about it is a game called little
inferno it's from the makers of world of
goo and it was actually released late
last year for the wii u and for pc one
of the quibbles that people had with
this was that it felt a little bit more
like an iOS game like something you drop
a couple bucks on and have some fun with
it is now satisfying that need it is
perfectly suited to this now on the face
of it little inferno is a strange thing
to describe it is essentially a
fireplace simulator you basically buy
toys buy things and then you burn them
and it's always fun to burn things but
this is really a puzzle game you are
given clues that hint at recipes of
combinations of things that you burn to
unlock the next things and kind of
progress in the game as you get deeper
into the game and mysterious story line
starts to emerge now it's fun about this
is obviously you have the kind of
surface level the game itself but the
subtext of this is kind of nicely
satirical it really takes aim at the
much-derided zynga model in games like
farmville that kind of force you to buy
things in the game in order to get ahead
so this this turns that on his head
really nicely it is a perfectly suited i
OS port I suppose it's really well well
situated on this kind of device that's
the way in my opinion it was meant to be
played and I'm glad it is here that is
out this week little Inferno on the iOS
App Store that's another definite pick
up so that is it for the monitor this
week we will be back next week with all
the news and pop culture but until then
inspirational catchphrase here